This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。嘿，大家最近怎么样？欢迎收听《以防万一》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）。这个节目聚焦黑人男性的生活经历，进行坦诚的对话——这些对话在其他任何地方进行其实都不太安全，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的执业专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着一套精神盔甲。这向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做。收听“Learn the Hard
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
Way”，可在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》（2%）中，我将剖析我们这个奇异现代世界中精神坚韧、健身以及建立心理韧性的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即TWO%，可在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个惯犯骗手约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应得的惩罚。我们常说，相信你的闺蜜。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
收听《闺蜜，相信我，宝贝》（the girlfriends. Trust me, babe），可在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回看过去》（Look Back at it）播客中。从1979年开始，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我意义重大。我是山姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利希（Alex English）。在每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode.
和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家一起。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论80年代那样。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。收听《回看过去》，可在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听友、老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能来到这里收听新的一期节目。
Today's episode, though, you may have already noticed, is a rerun. So over the next two weeks, I am putting out some of my best episodes from the last four years of almost, non-stop podcasting as I just take some time away to launch my debut book, Person in Progress, A Roadmap to the Psychology of Your 20s. Do not fret, I will be back on the 29th of April, but I just wanted to give my book a little bit of extra love these next two weeks because it's a big deal and I'm not going to talk about it too much. I'm sure you're just here to listen to the podcast and probably sick of me talking about it,
不过，大家可能已经注意到了，今天的节目是一期重播。所以在接下来的两周里，我将推出过去四年近乎不间断的播客创作中一些最精彩的节目，因为我要抽出一些时间来推出我的处女作《成长中的人：二十岁心理学指南》（Person in Progress, A Roadmap to the Psychology of Your 20s）。不用担心，我将在4月29日回归，但我只是想在接下来的两周里给我的书多一点额外的关注，因为这是一件大事，而且我不会过多地谈论它。我确信你们来这里只是为了听播客，大概也听腻了我谈论这本书，
but I just want to say thank you. I want to say a huge thank you for allowing me to write this book. book and put it out in the world. This is only possible because of you all, because of you guys, the listeners. That's it. That's the only reason I'm able to do this. And I wanted to be an author since I was five, 20 years later. You guys made that happen for me.
但我只想说谢谢。我要非常感谢大家允许我写这本书并把它带给全世界。这只有在你们所有人的支持下才可能实现，也就是你们这些听友。就是这样。这就是我能够做到这一点的唯一原因。我从五岁起就想成为一名作家，20年后。是你们帮我实现了这个愿望。
So just thank you. Thank you so much. I would obviously love it if you could pre-order it, buy it, gift it to a friend. But you've already done so much. And I just feel honored to have had this opportunity. most of all I'm just really pumped for you guys to read it. I hope that you learn something. I'm sure if you love the podcast, you will love person in progress as well, but it's a really exciting time. And the main feeling I have right now is one of gratitude. So thank you so much. Without further ado,
所以非常感谢你们。非常感谢。如果你们能预购、购买或把它作为礼物送给朋友，我当然会很高兴。但你们已经做得够多了。能有这个机会，我感到非常荣幸。最重要的是，我真的非常期待你们去读这本书。我希望你们能有所收获。我相信，如果你喜欢这个播客，你也会喜欢《成长中的人》（person in progress），这是一个非常激动人心的时刻。我现在最大的感受就是感激。所以非常感谢大家。废话不多说，
I hope you enjoy this rerun of one of my favorite all-time episodes. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody, welcome back to the show, welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode, as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. If nothing else, our 20s are this kind of beautiful time of transformation and reinvention that is a universal truth, a universal statement for me, that each of us, no matter what we're
希望你们喜欢这期我最喜欢的往期节目重播。大家好，欢迎回到《二十岁心理学》（the psychology of your 20s），在这里我们探讨二十岁时面临的一些重大生活变化与转型，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。大家好，欢迎回到节目，欢迎回到播客，新听友，老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能来到这里收听新的一期节目，当然，我们将在节目中剖析二十岁的心理学。如果说我们的二十岁有什么特点，那就是它是一段美丽而又充满转型与重塑的时期，对我来说，这是一个普遍真理、普遍规律：无论我们正在经历什么，
going through, what we're struggling with, what we do or don't achieve, we will have to rediscover time and time again who we are. and we also have to rediscover how far off that is from who we want to be, probably hundreds of times during this period of emerging adulthood. We spend so much of childhood and also our teenage years being the person that others want us to be or rebelling against this version entirely to carve out what we think is our own space. And I think our 20s is when we start to find balance and we really get the chance to do that all over again. and independently, and we approach self-discovery with a new maturity and a new sense of truth,
无论我们在与什么挣扎，无论我们取得了什么或没有取得什么成就，在步入成年初期的这段时间里，我们都不得不一次又一次地重新发现自己是谁。我们还得成百上千次地重新发现，现在的自己距离理想中的自己到底还有多远。在童年和青少年时期，我们花了大量时间去扮演别人希望我们成为的人，或者通过彻底反叛这种形象来开辟我们认为属于自己的空间。我认为，正是在二十岁的时候，我们开始寻找平衡，并且真正有机会重新开始这一切，
things about us become a lot more clear. And what we're likely to experience is a bit of a metamorphosis and a shedding of the old into the new. This is definitely a rite of passage, and sometimes it's deeply uncomfortable. But when you get to the point of not really enjoying your life, not liking who you are, not knowing what you stand for, what your dreams are, who you even want to be. You are really, I think, called to a place of reinvention. And that is what I want to talk about today. How can we reinvent and rediscover ourselves in our 20s when things start to
并且是独立地，带着一种新的成熟度和新的真实感来探索自我，关于我们的事情变得越来越清晰。我们很可能会经历一次蜕变，将陈旧的过去剥离，迎接崭新的自我。这绝对是一个成长的成年礼，有时它会让人感到极度不适。但当你开始真正厌倦生活、不喜欢自己、不知道自己坚信什么、不知道自己的梦想是什么、甚至不知道自己想成为什么样的人时，我认为，你其实是在被召唤前往一个重新塑造自我的地方。这正是我今天想谈论的话题。当生活开始让人感到
feel stagnant or off or we start to feel a sense of disconnection between who we are right now and who we really want to be. How do we kind of shake things up? How do we find our path? How do we have that refresh where we fall back in love with our lives through our old actions? Well, we are going to talk through five tips that you can work through either step by step or you can kind of choose one or the other for reinvention during this decade. This includes some methods. for visualizing your next chapter and how to use psychology to really motivate yourself to get there. How to use psychology to motivate a sense of confidence. Also how we can use that discomfort, use the boredom, the isolation, the stagnation, the uncertainty in our favor, rather than fighting against it.
停滞不前、不对劲，或者当我们开始感觉到现在的自己和真正想成为的自己之间出现断层时，我们该如何在二十岁时重塑和重新发现自己？我们如何才能打破常规？如何才能通过改变旧有行为，找回那种与生活重新坠入爱河的焕然一新的感觉？好吧，我们接下来将探讨五个小建议，你既可以一步步来，也可以在这一十年中选择其中一两项来实现自我重塑。其中包括一些方法：
How can we actually take all of those things that are making us crave reinvention and help us get there? rather than kind of, I don't know, burden us. We are also going to discuss the power of risk and this construct called the timeline for change and how to shift from very anxious, what if thinking, to a what else or so what mentality, which is honestly one of my favorite ways to think about this.
如何想象你的下一个篇章，以及如何利用心理学真正激励自己到达那里。如何利用心理学来激发自信心。以及我们如何将那种不适感、无聊感、孤立感、停滞感、不确定性转化为对我们有利的因素，而不是去抗拒它们。我们究竟如何才能把所有这些让我们渴望重塑自我的东西，转化为推动我们前进的动力，而不是把它们变成某种，我不知道，负担。我们还将探讨风险的力量，以及一个叫做“改变时间线”的概念，以及如何从高度焦虑的“如果……怎么办”的想法，转变为“还能怎样”或“那又怎样”的心态，老实说，这是我最喜欢的思考方式之一。
One of my favorite ideas in this space is that switch, that mental and cognitive switch, from seeing things in a disaster scenario lens or from a disaster scenario lens to an abundant lens from an abundant position of excess and authenticity and growth. I've got to say this is one of my favorite episodes that I've done as of recent because it just combines all my favorite nuggets of advice and theories into one package. And truly it really represents so much of my philosophy towards this. period in our lives. You know, our 20s are for exploration. They are for reinvention, rebuilding,
在这个领域，我最喜欢的理念之一就是那种转变，即从灾难情景的视角转变为丰盛视角，从一种丰盛、真实和成长的立场出发。我必须说，这是我最近做过最喜欢的节目之一，因为它把我所有最喜欢的建议和理论精华浓缩到了一个包里。而且它真的代表了我对人生这个阶段的大部分哲学思考。你知道，二十岁就是用来探索的。比起其他任何时期，这个时期更是用来重塑、重建和转型的。所以我真的希望我们能为自己开启这种可能，哪怕是通过微小的步骤，哪怕它并不像你想象的那那么激进。另外，我想每当我一有机会谈论风险以及我们面对不确定性的态度时，这就像是我最喜欢的话题，因为我深深地、深深地认为，很重要的一点是，我们应该停止将风险视为可怕的事情，而开始将风险视为一种投资。它真的符合重塑自我的整体概念和主题。所以我非常高兴能谈论这个。我很热情，充满活力。所以废话不多说，让我们进入在二十岁重塑自我的五种方法。
transformation more so than any other time. So I really want us to be able to unlock that for ourselves, even if it's through small steps, even if it's not as drastic as you're picturing. Also, I guess whenever I get the opportunity to talk about risk and our approach to uncertainty, that is like a favorite topic of mine because it's something that I deeply, deeply think is important that we stop seeing risk is scary and we start seeing risk as investment. It really falls into this overall concept and topic of reinvention. So I am very excited to talk about this. I'm enthused. I'm invigorated. So I think without further ado, let us get into the five ways that we can reinvent ourselves. in our 20s.
重塑自我，改变生活，我认为这真的必须从找出你目前的处境、日常生活中究竟是什么、以及哪些习惯让你感到不满开始。你目前对生活的总体感受是什么，
Reinventing yourself, changing your life, I think it really has to begin with identifying what it is about your current circumstances, your day-to-day, your habits, that are dissatisfying to you. What is the main feeling that you have towards your life at the moment
正是这种感受让你产生了想要改变现状的悸动，让你感到坐立不安？我认为在二十岁时，有几种主要的感受特别值得注意。第一种是无聊，无聊会让你觉得生活中好像没发生什么事。没有什么令人兴奋的事发生。没有什么在改变。你也没有在改变。那些真正提升我们日常生活体验的元素，比如冒险、刺激、即兴。它们全都不见了。
that is giving you this itch to change things up, that is making you restless? There are a few big ones that I think are specifically noteworthy. in our 20s. The first one is boredom, boredom feeling like not much is happening in your life. Nothing exciting is happening. Nothing is changing. You're not changing. The things that really elevate our day-to-day experiences like adventure, like excitement, like spontaneity. It's just not
只剩下这种平淡无奇的感觉。无聊是第一种。接下来是停滞。这和无聊非常相似，但它更多地集中在这样一种感觉上：你在生活的某个领域变得自满，即使你仍在做有趣的事情。这尤其与我们的职业生涯或一些更大的目标有关，你会发现，你知道，你并没有像你预期的那样，或者像过去那样朝着某个目标努力，从而感到非常卡壳。然后是孤立感，缺乏联系，缺乏社群，感到孤独，或许伴随着一种害怕错过的心理（FOMO），觉得自己错过了其他人在这段时期似乎正在经历的种种体验。然后是最后一种
there. It's this sense of just like plainness. Bordom is the first one. Then we have stagnation. And this is very similar to boredom, but it's more so centered on a sense. that you've kind of become complacent in some domain of your life, even if you're still doing fun things. This is particularly to do with our careers or to do with some larger goal, finding that, you know, you're really not working towards something the way that you anticipated that you would be or the way that you have in the past, feeling very stuck. Then we have isolation, lacking connection, lacking community, feeling lonely and maybe with that, you know, some phomo that you're out on the experiences that others seem to be having during this time. And then the final
同样让我们对改变感到迫切的感受，就是一种普遍的不适感，这种感觉可能非常类似于焦虑，即你生活中的某样东西就是不太对劲。你似乎再也无法融入你目前的处境了。你知道，你的身体会本能地告诉你，你有这些习惯、这些朋友、这些处境，这不是我们想要的。我们在这里并不舒服。我们在这里并不快乐。通常，它会通过高度的敏感、极度的神经质、以及不断将你带回你所面临的某个问题的重复思维来表现出来，表现为你知道自己可以成为的人与现在的自己之间存在着一种疏离感。所以这些感受——无聊、停滞、孤立和不适，它们在告诉我们一些
feeling that I think also makes us quite itchy for change is just a general discomfort, a feeling that's probably very similar to anxiety, that something about your life just isn't quite right. You don't seem to fit in your current circumstances anymore. You know, you have these habits, these friends, these situations that your body is very instinctually telling you, this is a is not what we want. We're not comfortable here. We're not happy here. And often it does that through heightened sensitivity, being very nervous, repetitive thoughts that are again and again bringing you back to some issue that you're having, a sense of detachment between who you know you can be and who you are now. So these feelings, boredom, stagnation, isolation and discomfort, they tell us something
非常有用的信息，尽管它们并不令人愉快。它们告诉我们的是，我们需要改变，我们需要转变，我们需要做点不一样的事情，最好是趁早，而不是迟做。我之所以说趁早而不是迟做，是因为如果你不采取行动，不是立刻，而是很快，那么替代的结局就是，我们开始对这种不适感习以为常。我们习惯了无聊、孤独、卡壳，并且认为这是正常的。在心理学中，这个过程实际上被称为习惯化。它指的是随着时间的推移，我们对那些曾经让我们沮丧或困扰的事情变得越来越习以为常的倾向。你知道，我想到了，比如我，我实际上住在一条航线下，
very useful, even though it's unpleasant. And what they're telling us is that we need to change, we need to shift, we need to be doing something different, and hopefully sooner rather than later. The reason that I say sooner rather than later is because if you don't do something, not instantly, but pretty soon, the alternative is that we begin to get quite comfortable with the discomfort. it. We get comfortable with being bored, with being lonely, with being stuck, and we think that that's normal. In psychology, this process is actually called habituation. And it refers to our tendency to get more and more used to something that used to frustrate us or bother us as time goes on. You know, I think about, so I, for example, I actually live under like a plane line, what's it
叫什么来着，就是飞行航线，对吧？当我刚搬进这所房子时，飞机从头顶飞过的声音简直太烦人了，让我极其困扰。那是我脑子里唯一的想法。但住得越久，我甚至都注意不到它了。就像，我敢肯定在我录音的这段时间里，大约有五架飞机从我房子上方的天空飞过，但我已经习惯了。当我们对本不该习惯的事物感到习以为常时，发生的也是同样的事情。你不应该对生活中的无聊、孤立或停滞感到习惯。
called like a flight path, right? And when I first moved into this house, like the sound of planes going overhead was so, would just bother me so much. It was all I could think about. But the longer that I've lived here, I don't even notice it anymore. Like, I'm sure that about five planes have probably flown over the skies above my house in the time that I've been recording this, but I've become habituated. And that is the same thing that happens when we get comfortable with something that we should not be comfortable with. You should not be comfortable with being born in your life or being isolated or being, you know, stagnant.
我们只有一个非常小的窗口期来阻止这种习惯化的发生并采取行动。否则，事情就会变得越来越难。这就像戒掉一个坏习惯。我们要探讨的是，如果我们把这些情绪状态完全颠倒过来，生活会是什么样子。所以，当我们感到无聊时，我们承诺去追求刺激；当我们感到停滞时，我们承诺去追求成长；用联结去战胜孤立，用平静和边界去战胜不适感。
And we have a really small window to stop that habituation from happening and to act. Otherwise, it does get harder and harder. It's like breaking a bad habit. What we want to explore is what life would look like if we flipped those emotional states to be the complete opposite. So when we felt bored, we made a commitment to pursue excitement. When we felt stagnant, we made a commitment to pursue growth, to pursue connection over isolation, to pursue peace and boundaries over discomfort.
所以我希望你做的，首先是注意到是什么在驱动你想要重塑或刷新生活，然后制定一个为期30天的计划，去做所有与那种最初感受截然相反的事情。我们要彻底震撼你的生活，趁你现在还对这种不适感保持着动力。例如，如果你现在对生活感到非常无聊，我希望你在便签应用上或在一张纸上列一个清单，贴在冰箱上，写下一系列你一直想在你的城市或小镇上做却还没做过的活动。我希望你承诺每两三天、每三天就去做一件，
So what I want from you is to really, to begin with, notice what is driving you to want to reinvent or refresh your life and then make a plan for the next 30 days to do all the things that feel the exact opposite to that initial feeling. We're going to really shake up your life whilst you're still feeling motivated by the discomfort. For example, if you are just feeling so bored with your life right now, I want you to make a list in your notes up or on a sheet of paper to put on your fridge of a series of activities that you've always wanted to do in your city or your town that you haven't. And I want you to be committed to doing one every two days, every three days,
或者如果你一直想报个班、培养个爱好，那就报名参加一个需要你周复一周去上课的为期六周的课程，办一张新的健身卡，做一些完全不同的事情。新奇的体验确实会给人一种在生活中创造了更多时间的错觉。围绕这一点，2016年有一项变得广为人知的研究发现，随着年龄的增长，时间似乎确实过得更快了。这并不是因为时间真的过得更快了，而是因为我们学到的东西变少了。我们接触到的新鲜事物变少了。
or if there is a class, a hobby you've always wanted to pursue, sign up for a six-week course that you have to go to week after a week, get a new gym membership, just do something different. Novel experiences quite literally give the impression of creating more time in our lives. And there's a 2016 study around this that has become quite well known that found that the older we get, time does seem to actually pass quicker. not because it's actually going any faster, but because we are learning less. We are exposed to fewer new things.
我们对已知的事物越来越习以为常。但真正创造出“时间变多”这种心理体验的，其实是新奇感和新鲜事物。而这正是我们需要重新引入的东西，以此来把我们从走向冷漠和单调的道路上拉回来。所以把刺激感重新带回你的生活，因为这是一个你可以做出的选择。你知道，这是你可以靠自己去改变的事情，用以重塑你对现状的看法。如果你感到停滞不前，情况也是如此，找出那个停滞的领域，然后列出一系列你知道能帮自己打破僵局的事情。如果是工作相关的，我发现通常都是这样，或者与职业相关，我希望你改变你的日常。我希望你每天花30分钟申请新工作，而不是刷手机。
We become more accustomed to what we already know. But what actually creates the mental experience of more time is novelty and newness. And that is what we need to reintroduce to kind of pull us out of the path towards indifference and monotony. So put the excitement back in your life because that is a choice for you. You know, that is something that you can change on your own to reinvent how you feel about your circumstances. The same goes for if you're feeling stagnant, you know, identify what area that's in and make yourself a list of a series of things that you know would help you break out of that. If it's work related, which I find it often is or career related, I want you to change your routine. I want you to spend 30 minutes a day applying for new jobs instead of scrolling.
我希望你去建立人脉。我希望你去联系那些你在网上钦佩的人，发送那些求职邮件，这样当你上床睡觉时，你会有一种自己有所成就的感觉。你知道，报名参加社交活动。思考你接下来可以做什么。我认为重塑自我完全关乎行动，选择你想走的方向并真正去追求它。一旦你尝试将无聊、停滞或其他任何消极感受的拨盘朝相反方向拨动之后，是时候开始真正构想你的下一个时代以及这个全新的版本将成为谁了，
I want you to be networking. I want you to be, you know, reaching out to people that you admire online, shooting off those emails, so that when you go to bed, you have a sense that you've done something. You know, sign up for the networking event. Contemplate what you could do next. I think reinvention is all about movement and picking the direction you want to go in and actually pursuing it. Once you've kind of tested sliding the dial to your boredom, your stagnation, whatever it is in the opposite direction, it's time to really begin to visualize your next era and who this new version of you will be,
还要构想这个全新的你会如何行动。你知道，在你最狂野的幻想中，在你最宏大、最大的梦想里，你真实的自我究竟是谁？回望镜子里的那个角色是谁？如果你仍然不确定那是谁，甚至不知道该如何去想象这个版本的自己，我有一些问题可以真正帮助你将这个人的某些元素
but also how this new version of you will act. You know, in your wildest fantasies, your greatest, largest dreams, who is your authentic self? Who is the character staring back at you? If you still are unsure about who that is, how to even visualize this version of yourself, I have some questions to really help you bring elements. of this person forward. So what are some of the dreams that you've had for as long as you can remember that you've always put off?
带到现实中来。那么，有什么梦想是你记事起就一直拥有却总是搁置的呢？
What truly excites you? What could you talk about for hours? In five years time, what would your ideal but average day in your life look like? And how is that different from now? What chapter of your life are you ready to close and what is holding you back from closing that chapter? Or what is holding you back from putting everything. behind the truest version of yourself. Your answers to these questions should really begin to
什么真正让你兴奋？有什么话题是你可以滔滔不绝聊上几个小时的？五年后，你理想中但又普通的一天会是什么样？这与现在有什么不同？你准备好结束生活中的哪个篇章了，是什么在阻止你结束这个篇章？或者是什么在阻止你把一切
direct you to what this next era of your life is going to bring. You know, if you were to look back, I think, and if we were to look back at past versions, you know, past parts of our life story, you start to really see in hindsight these strange lines or periods that are carved into your memories. You begin to notice that life isn't one long sequence. of events and I guess it is but actually it's a series of seasons and a series of periods within which you've had different goals, maybe different friends, different ambitions, different, you know, sense of style, maybe you've even lived in a different place, your routine was different. We each have these different errors or chapters of our lives
抛在脑后，去成为最真实的自己？你对这些问题的回答应该真正开始引导你走向生活下一个时代将要带来的东西。你知道，如果你回首过去，我认为，如果我们回首过去的不同版本，回首我们生活故事中的过去片段，你开始真正从后见之明中看到那些刻在你记忆中的奇怪线条或时期。你会开始注意到，生活并不是一长串
that represent who we were and what we were going through at that time. And this next error for you is going to be one of authenticity. It's going to be one where you're going to channel all of those deeply rooted dreams and values and goals and actually just spend the next six months to a year prioritizing them. That is how you're going to bring yourself into this next chapter and reinvent yourself. We can be in the business of deciding when a new season begins for us, regardless of what is happening externally. And that really starts with being able to see, feel, touch, hear, experience what this new era represents for you before it even emerges.
事件的序列，我想它确实是，但实际上它是一系列季节，是一系列时期，在这些时期里你有着不同的目标、或许不同的朋友、不同的雄心、不同的审美感、甚至你可能住在不同的地方，你的日常也不同。我们每个人都有生活中不同的时代或篇章，它们代表了我们是谁以及我们当时正在经历什么。而对你来说，下一个时代将是充满真实性的一代。它将是一个让你引导所有那些根深蒂固的梦想、价值观和目标，并在接下来的六个月到一年里优先考虑它们的时代。这就是你如何将自己带入这个新篇章并重塑自我的方式。我们可以自主决定一个新季节何时为我们拉开帷幕，而不管外部正在发生什么。而这确实始于这样一种能力：在它甚至还没有显现之前，就能看到、感受到、触摸到、听到、体验到这个新时代为你代表着什么。
And you've already done that in a way. By focusing on those questions that we were talking about before, you do already have an idea. But then you have to get it out of your mind into some physical form, either through action or through something like visualization. So some ways that people do this is through like vision boards, you know, spending an afternoon, really putting to page. or a poster, what this next chapter looks like for you, you know, with pictures of destinations that you'll visit and accomplishments and the nature that you'll see, the mornings that you'll have, the hobbies that will relax you. You need to have an idea of what you're actually aiming for here. And visualization is extremely psychologically powerful. There was a recent study that said
在某种程度上，你已经做到了这一点。通过专注于我们之前讨论过的那些问题，你其实已经有了一个想法。但随后你必须把它从你的脑海中带出来，转化为某种物理形式，无论是通过行动还是通过像可视化这样的方法。所以人们做到这一点的一些方法是通过制作愿景板（vision boards），你知道，花一个下午的时间，真正把这个新篇章对你来说是什么样的写在纸上
about a quarter of successful entrepreneurs use vision boards or a similar process to map out change for themselves. And there was a 2019 study that also suggests that vision boards, as much as we sometimes think that they're silly, actually no, they almost double an individual's level of confidence in their ability to effectively execute actions necessary to achieve a desired outcome. And it really promotes people to seek out supportive resources. And it keeps this vision of who they want to be, who they're working towards very squarely in the front of their mind. Because life is full of distractions. There are lots of things pulling us this way, that way.
或贴在海报上，配上你将要访问的目的地的照片、成就、你将看到的风景、你将拥有的清晨、让你放松的爱好。你需要对你在这里真正追求的目标有一个概念。而可视化在心理上具有极大的威力。最近的一项研究表明，
You know, you're busy. You know, there's people's expectations. There's money to worry about. There's, you know, relationships to worry about. But this method really squarely says, very deeply says, no, this is what we're working towards right now. This is who we want to be. another way to do this if visualization and you know mood boards vision boards sorry aren't really your
大约四分之一的成功企业家使用愿景板或类似的过程来为自己规划变革。2019年的一项研究还表明，尽管有时我们认为愿景板很傻，但实际上并非如此，它们实际上使个人对其有效执行实现预期结果所需行动的能力的信心水平翻了一番。它确实促使人们寻找支持性资源。并且它将他们想成为的人、他们正在努力实现的目标的愿景，非常清晰地保持在他们脑海的最前沿。因为生活充满了干扰。有很多事情把我们拉向这个方向，拉向那个方向。
favorite method it's to identify a theme for your new error that you really want to embody and that you will use to charge motivate direct everything that you're doing in this new season as in you know when it's time to make a decision or you have a hard choice ahead of you I want you to have that one theme, that one word that decisively chooses for you. Let me explain this a little bit more. So with this new error, your theme could be discipline. It could be reinvention, rebirth, passion, creativity, authenticity, exploration, intuition, focus, courage.
你知道，你很忙。你知道，有来自他人的期望。有需要担心的金钱。有需要担心的关系。但这种方法非常直接、非常深刻地表明：不，这才是我们目前正在努力的方向。这才是我们想要成为的人。如果你喜欢的不是可视化和情绪板、愿景板之类的，
I want you to choose one of those or one of your own, a theme that is going to sit at the core of everything you aim to do for the next six months. Let me use the theme of reinvention here to explain why this works. You know, it's very appropriate for this episode. But to embody reinvention, that really means doing things differently, right? Making space for what's new, making space for things that you haven't tried before. Maybe because you're scared, you're embarrassed, you're held back by the judgments of others. But you're going to do it anyways.
那么另一个方法是为你的新时代确定一个你真正想要体现的主题，你将用它来引领、激励、指导你在新季节中所做的一切。比如，当到了做出决定的时候，或者你面临艰难的选择时，我希望你拥有那一个主题，那一个能为你果断做出选择的词。让我对这一点做更多一点的解释。所以对于这个新时代，你的主题可以是纪律。它可以是重塑、重生、激情、创造力、真实性、探索、直觉、专注、勇气。
You are stepping into this new era. You're reinventing yourself. So if someone invites you to a party that you'd normally not go to and you're kind of uming and a-ring about whether you want to go, you have an easy solution here. What decision would best align with that theme, reinvention? The decision that best aligns is to go to the party. That is your directive. If you're, you know, back and forthing over living the house in, I don't know, an outfit that you probably never wear and you're like, maybe I should take this off.
我希望你选择其中一个或你自己的主题，一个将成为你在接下来的六个月里旨在做的一切的核心的主题。让我在这里用“重塑”这个主题来解释为什么这行得通。你知道，这非常适合这一集。但要体现重塑，真的意味着以不同的方式做事，对吧？为新鲜事物腾出空间，为那些你从未尝试过的事情腾出空间。也许是因为你害怕、尴尬、受到他人判断的阻碍。但你无论如何都要去做。
I don't really know, well, you have to be guided by reinvention above all else. Everything is coming back to this theme for the next six months. It is a very simple, you know, compass for you, a decision-making tool that's like, okay, if I'm faced with two choices, the one that best aligns with my theme is the one that I have to do, is the one that I need to pursue. This is just such a powerful, I think, mental trick. because sometimes we like set out to reinvent our lives and like you know you kind of try and do a whole overhaul and you want to change everything right now at once and eventually like this version of you that
你正在步入这个新时代。你正在重塑自我。所以如果有人邀请你去一个你通常不会去的派对，而你还在犹豫要不要去，你这里有一个简单的解决方案。什么决定最符合“重塑”这个主题？最符合的决定就是去参加派对。这就是你的行动指南。如果你在纠结要不要穿一件你可能从不穿的衣服出门，然后你想：也许我该把它脱下来。
you're actually aiming for gets a little bit lost in all the chaos when you simplify it when you bring it back to one theme and one theme only you are just better able to truly focus and not get caught up in the clutter and not get caught up in the chaos that transformation often brings. Moving beyond this method, let's now turn to some longer-term activities for refreshing, recharging your life in your 20s, specifically to do with goal setting. Now, I'm going to say something that might be controversial, that might be unexpected. But goal setting to me is one of the most boring things to talk about in the world. And that might surprise you, but I really struggle.
我真的不知道。好吧，你必须把“重塑”奉为最高指导原则。在接下来的六个月里，一切都要回归到这个主题上来。它对你来说是一个非常简单的指南针、一个决策工具，就像是：好吧，如果我面临两个选择，那个最符合我主题的选择就是我必须去做的，就是我需要去追求的。我认为这是一个非常强大的心理技巧。因为有时我们着手重塑生活时，你知道，你会试图进行彻底的重组，你想要立刻同时改变所有事情，最终，你真正想要成为的那个版本的你，
to be around people who have a million goals for every single thing in their life. Because it just feels so intense and disciplined to me. And my natural inclination is and was to really feel my way through things and to like go with my gut rather than having like a two year, five year plan. You know, I could work very hard at things for a long period of time. But, you know, I wasn't really into resetting goals every six months and planning out where I wanted to be and doing distinct, things to make that happen. I have slowly begun to retire that philosophy that, you know, I think I
会在所有的混乱中变得有点迷失。当你把它简化时，当你把它归结为一个主题，且仅有一个主题时，你就更能真正专注于此，而不会陷入杂乱之中，也不会陷入转型往往带来的混乱之中。超越了这个方法之后，让我们现在转向一些长期活动，用于在二十岁时刷新、重塑你的生活，特别是与设定目标有关的活动。现在，我要说一件可能会引起争议、可能会出乎意料的事情。但在我看来，设定目标是世界上最无聊的话题之一。这可能会让你感到惊讶，但我真的很难
was misguided. I thought that goal setting had to be really intensive. Um, when actually, no, it doesn't have to be that way. It doesn't have to make you an ultra disciplined person. Actually, it's really about change, right? And, you know, as we always say, nothing changes if you don't. And in a similar vein, nothing changes if you can't imagine them changing. And that is really what goal setting is all about. Saying to yourself, this could be different. This part of my life, my routine, my lifestyle, my job could be different and I could be happier.
和那些在生活方方面面都有一百万个目标的人相处。因为这让我觉得太紧张、太有纪律性了。我天生的倾向是，过去是，现在也是，靠感觉去体验事物，跟着自己的直觉走，而不是制定什么两年计划、五年计划。你知道，我可以长时间非常努力地工作。但是，你知道，我其实并不热衷于每六个月重置一次目标，规划我想去的地方，并做具体的事情来让它发生。我慢慢开始摒弃那种哲学，你知道，我认为
And I'm going to trust myself and I'm going to believe that I am capable of doing that, of bringing about that change. I think instead of having one big goal that is miles away, I was recently introduced to this concept called the timeline for change. And the timeline for change is another way of conceptualizing your goals or setting up benchmarks that is a bit less intensive and more daily and broken down into these small pieces. You have a one year goal, a six month goal, a monthly goal, and a daily goal, or what we would typically call a micro habit, the thing that you do each day that hopefully builds to the big win at the end.
我当时被误导了。我以为设定目标必须是非常密集的。而实际上，不，它不一定非得那样。它不必把你变成一个极度自律的人。实际上，它真的关乎改变，对吧？而且，正如我们常说的，如果你不改变，什么都不会改变。与之类似，如果你连改变的想象力都没有，什么也不会改变。而这正是设定目标的关键所在。对自己说：这可以是不一样的。我生活中的这一部分、我的日常、我的生活方式、我的工作都可以是不一样的，而且我可以更快乐。
You can really then apply this like timeline for change to whatever area you desire, whatever area needs reinvention needs a refresh. It could be career, friendship, health, finance is a creative passion. Think about, you know, transforming your health, for example. You know, perhaps your timeline for change would be to every day walk for 30 minutes and then your one-month goal would be to go to the gym twice a week. Your six-month goal is to run a 5K and by one year to have a gym routine and be able to run 10K. I think fitness-related goals slot very easily into the timeline for change. But you can kind of see how this method really
我会相信自己，并且我相信自己有能力做到这一点，有能力带来这种改变。我认为，与其有一个遥不可及的宏大目标，我最近接触到了一个叫做“改变时间线”的概念。而“改变时间线”是另一种将目标概念化或建立基准的方法，它没有那么密集，更加日常化，并被分解成这些小的部分。你有一个一年目标、六个月目标、每月目标和每日目标，或者我们通常称之为微习惯的目标——你每天都在做的事情，它有望为最后的巨大成功添砖加瓦。
allows you to combine both momentum and sustainable habit building with that long-term planning. You know, because your goals are sitting along a journey. They're sitting along a timeline. rather than just consisting of a start line, an ambitious, big dream, and a finish line, a sense of what is going to be like when you get there, and, you know, nothing in between. And I think that is exactly why most New Year's resolutions often fail. You know, there was a poll done by the University of Ohio that showed 23% of people will quit their New Year's resolutions by the end of January 7th and almost 50% by the second week, because we underestimate how much progress we're going to make.
然后，你可以真正将这个“改变时间线”应用到你渴望的任何领域，任何需要重塑、需要刷新的领域。它可以是职业、友谊、健康、财务或创造力激情。比如，考虑改变你的健康状况。也许你的改变时间线将是：每天步行30分钟，然后你的一个月目标是每周去两次健身房。你的六个月目标是跑完5公里，一年内拥有健身日常并能够跑10公里。我认为与健身相关的目标很容易融入改变时间线中。但你可以看出这种方法如何真正
So we think too big and we lack the positive reinforcement along the way because we're only thinking about the beginning and the end. And B, to enact those significant and immediate changes, you know, psychologically and physically speaking, it's very, very difficult. It's very difficult to just come in all guns blazing and change everything about your life. You need to build that foundation through consistency,
让你将动力和可持续的习惯养成与长期规划结合起来。你知道，因为你的目标是沿着一段旅程前进的。它们是沿着时间线前进的。而不是仅仅由一个起跑线、一个雄心勃勃的宏大梦想、一个终点线、以及到达那里时的感受组成，而中间却空无一物。我认为这正是大多数新年决议往往会失败的原因。俄亥俄大学做过的一项民意调查显示，23%的人在1月7日结束前就会放弃新年决议，近50%的人在第二周就会放弃，因为我们低估了我们将要取得的进展。
not through new peaks with random, you know, dashes of effort. So to summarize, our third tip, give yourself the necessary space for reinvention by making things actionable, by making things realistic and really implementing a sustainable timeline for change that you are both excited about, but is also very, very doable. Okay, my lovely listeners, we are going to take a short break, but when we're back, I want to discuss some more of, you know, more of our spontaneous, rebellious, maybe refreshing paths for change, a more energetic, you know, perspective on reinvention. We have a lot more to talk about. So please stay with us.
所以我们把目标定得太大，并且在沿途缺乏积极的强化，因为我们只考虑了开头和结尾。其次，从心理和生理上讲，要实施那些重大而直接的改变是非常非常困难的。一上来就气势汹汹地改变你生活的一切，这是非常困难的。你需要通过连贯一致性来建立基础，
2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
而不是通过随机努力带来的短暂高潮。总而言之，我们的第三个小建议：通过让事情具有可操作性、切合实际，并真正实施一个既让你感到兴奋、又非常非常可行的可持续改变时间线，来为重塑自我腾出必要的空间。好了，我可爱的听友们，我们要稍事休息，但当我们回来时，我想讨论更多关于我们更自发、更叛逆、也许更清爽的改变路径，一个对重塑更具活力、更有活力的视角。我们还有很多要谈的。所以请继续收听。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out, on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little Kim?
2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》（2%）中，我将剖析我们这个奇异现代世界中精神坚韧、健身以及建立心理韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员、其他健康与健身专家等展开对话，超越统治健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at a podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex Ingram. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack.
让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即TWO%，可在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA上拍了两次小肯姆（Lil Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？
So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
好吧，你可以在《回看过去》（Look Back at a podcast）播客中找到答案。我是山姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格拉姆（Alex Ingram）。在每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）一起大谈80年代的快克可卡因。需要明确的是，84年对我很重要，不只是因为快克。我随时准备在白天谈论快克，只是想让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，在这一点上，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch.
所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿线。我们现在也把爱滋病摆在了桌面上。谢谢你把那句话说完。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。收听《回看过去》，可在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。欢迎收听我的新播客《以防万一》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们的主持人，也是你们最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是。特里·方丹（Trip Fontaine），瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于陷入追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西。而我们还在继续追逐它。我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们总是在看记分牌。
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
生活渐渐变成了关于赢输。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你们觉得在人世间做一个好人很重要吗？你做一个好人是因为害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。而且这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你们能真正地做一个好人。
Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free IHeartRadio app. Search, learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023,
加入我，科尔·加恩斯，在我的新播客《狠狠吸取教训》（Learn the Hard Way）中，就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio 应用程序。搜索“Learn the Hard Way”并立即收听。在 2023 年，
former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case.
前《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这拉开了长达数年的正义维权法庭之战的序幕。你曾对某人篡改过两次这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案件。
I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap.
我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格、一个女同性恋者、迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的大脑彻底被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《爱情陷阱》。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. At some stage, you are going to have to do something that really scares you or that that you didn't think was possible if you want to grow into your next phase. Long-term goal setting, having a planning phase, visualizing, articulating what you want,
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这件事不会结束。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。在某个阶段，如果你想进入下一个发展阶段，你将不得不做一些真正让你害怕的事情，或者你以前认为不可能的事情。长远目标设定、规划阶段、可视化、清晰表达你想要什么，
labeling this new error for yourself is so wonderful. You know, by that stage, you really, you can't go wrong. But one of the easiest ways to almost guarantee transformation and to speed up your reinvention, your realignment is to take risks, big or small. risk in my mind is like the fast forward button there's less accuracy about where you're going to end up right like you're skipping through a movie you want to get to the action quicker but it means that you really propel yourself even faster into this new error there is not a single person that you admire that you respect you idolize whether that is professionally or personally that has gotten to where they are without being a little bit
为自己开启这个新时代是如此美妙。你知道，到了那个阶段，你真的，你不会出错。但几乎能保证转变并加速你的重塑和重新校准的最简单方法之一，就是承担风险，无论大小。在我看来，风险就像是快进按钮，你最终会去哪里，其准确度会降低，就像你在快进一部电影一样，你想更快地看到精彩情节，但这意味著你会以更快的速度将自己推进到这个新时代。没有任何一个人，是你所钦佩、尊重、甚至崇拜的——无论是职业上还是个人生活中——在没有感到一点
daunted and unsure of whether they made the right decision. You know, actually for me, if you're questioning whether you've made the right decision, you are exactly in the place you need to be because those are the decisions that really contribute to growth. Easy decisions feel great because they don't require you to really question anything fundamental about yourself. But hard decisions, risks, that is where you really have to look in the mirror and question, what do I actually want from my life? A lot of people don't do that. Another way I think about it is
畏惧、且不确定自己是否做出正确决定的情况下，就能取得今天的成就。你知道，实际上对我来说，如果你在质疑自己是否做出了正确的决定，那你正处在需要处于的位置，因为正是这些决定真正促进了成长。轻松的决定感觉很棒，因为它们不需要你真正去质疑关于你自己的任何根本性的东西。但艰难的决定、冒险，才是你真正需要照镜子并质问自己的地方：我到底想从生活中得到什么？很多人并没有这样做。我思考它的另一种方式是
how when we build muscle at the gym or when we're working out, what is actually happening are these micro tears. You know, things are ripping, space is being made, it's painful, but then those holes get filled with new mass and we grow. It's a strange analogy I know, but it's how I think about risk, you know, a small tears that are sometimes sore, that are sometimes unconsored, that are sometimes comfortable. I don't really know what you're doing. You don't really know what you're doing, but it needs to happen in order to bring about strength. And psychologically, risk is scary naturally, right? Because anything that's unfamiliar will cause our brain to have quite a natural hesitancy because it is hesitant towards the unknown. But just because your mind says something
就像我们在健身房练肌肉或锻炼身体时，实际发生的事情是这些微撕裂。你知道，组织在撕裂，空间在腾出，这是痛苦的，但随后这些空隙会被新的肌肉填满，我们就会成长。这是一个奇怪的比喻，我知道，但这就是我对风险的看法，你知道，有时候会痛的小撕裂，有时候未经审查，有时候很舒服。你其实不知道自己在做什么。你其实不知道自己在做什么，但这必须发生，才能带来力量。从心理学上讲，风险自然是可怕的，对吧？因为任何不熟悉的事物都会让我们的大脑产生一种自然的犹豫，因为它对未知事物感到迟疑。但仅仅因为你的脑海说某事
is scary doesn't necessarily mean it should be avoided. Actually, it might mean that, you might mean, the opposite. If you're going to do one thing to reinvent yourself during this decade, it's to take a risk that you've always wanted to, but never imagine that you could. And I'm going to give you like a rapid fire list as to why I believe this truly and deeply, and I want you to seriously try and rebut my reasons with the reasons why you shouldn't. Number one, you will never have as few responsibilities as you do now. Number two, you are the the youngest that you will ever be, probably with the least to lose. You will never have more time than you have right now.
很可怕，并不一定意味着它应该被避免。实际上，它可能意味着，你可能意味着，恰恰相反。如果你在这十年里要做一件事来重塑自己，那就是去冒一个你一直想冒、但从没想过自己能做到的险。我要给你一份连珠炮似的名单，告诉你为什么我深信不疑，我希望你认真尝试用你不该这么做的理由来反驳我的理由。第一，你永远不会像现在这样拥有这么少的责任。第二，你是你这一生中最年轻的时候，可能也是输得起的时候。你永远不会拥有比现在更多的时间。
I also think that risks are an investment. They are not a cost. They will benefit your life and your foundations way more than the risks that you don't take and way more than playing it safe. And finally, in a very similar vein, you are more likely to live with regret over the risks you didn't take, over the ones that you did. And if you want some anecdotal primary evidence of this,
我也认为风险是一项投资。它们不是成本。它们对你的生活和基础的好处，远远超过你不去冒的险，也远远超过墨守成规。最后，以非常相似的思路，比起你冒过的险，你更有可能为那些你没有冒的险而带着遗憾生活。如果你想为此寻找一些轶事层面的第一手证据，
ask your parents or your grandparents next time you see them what their biggest regrets are. And I would say 80% of the time your parents are going to say, oh, you know, the time I didn't travel, the time I was too scared to do that thing that I should have, the time that I didn't tell that person I loved them, the time that I said no to an opportunity that I really actually should have taken
下次见到你的父母或祖父母时，问问他们最大的遗憾是什么。我想说，80% 的情况下，你的父母都会说，哦，你知道的，我没有去旅行的那次，我当时太害怕而没做那件事的那次，我没有对那个人说我爱他们的那次，我对一个我其实真的应该抓住的机会说不的那次，
because of imposter syndrome. Regret often feeds off inaction rather than action. Here's the thing. Reinventing yourself through risk doesn't have to be dramatic. Some of us get really paralyzed by this idea that to move forward, we have to do something we are deeply uncertain of. And normally this is the case if you're quite risk-averse, right? So in psychology and economics even,
因为冒名顶替综合症。遗憾往往是由不作为而不是作为滋养的。事情是这样的。通过冒险来重塑自我并不一定是戏剧性的。我们中的一些人被这种想法彻底搞瘫痪了：为了前进，我们必须做一些我们深感不确定的事情。通常情况正是如此，如果你相当厌恶风险的话，对吧？所以在心理学甚至经济学中，
there are these different profiles of the types of people in their perspective on risk. There are risk positive people, people who will put it all on the line very frequently without really considering the costs. There are risk neutral people, people who are very practical, almost mathematical about the costs and benefits of a risk. And then there are risk-averse individuals. Those of us whose minds just naturally exaggerate the consequences and the costs of the risk over the benefits to the point where the risk actually seems entirely ridiculous. You know, we are convinced that we should, always play it safe. And if that is you, if the idea of moving to a new country knowing
这些不同类型的人在对风险的看法上有不同的画像。有风险偏好型的人，他们会非常频繁地把一切都押上去，而没有真正考虑成本。有风险中立型的人，他们非常务实，几乎是以数学的方式看待风险的成本和收益。然后是风险厌恶型的个人。我们这些人，脑海中会自然而然地夸大风险的后果和成本，甚至超过其收益，以至于风险看起来完全荒谬。你知道，我们确信自己应该永远求稳。如果那就是你，如果搬到一个不认识任何人的新国家、
no one, quitting your job without anything lined up, if that is really, really scary, what I want you to adopt is this idea of micro risks, things that you can slowly incorporate to almost increase your tolerance for the uncertainty that comes along with these decisions. You can go on solo dates. You can go on micro adventures on. the weekend solo. You don't have to travel across the world. You can book an Airbnb for the weekend in the mountains near a national park somewhere like an hour or two away and just enjoy a new part of the world alone. My cousin Stella actually, she was just messaging me about her solo camping trip that she's been on for the last two to three days. Literally she's only like an hour or two
在毫无准备的情况下辞掉工作，如果这真的、真的很可怕，我希望你采纳的是微风险的概念，你可以慢慢把这些事情融入生活中，以提高你对这些决定所带来的不确定性的耐受力。你可以去进行单人约会。你可以在周末独自进行微冒险。你不必周游世界。你可以在山里的国家公园附近找个离家一两小时车程的地方，通过周末在爱彼迎上订个房间，独自享受世界的一个新角落。实际上我的表妹斯特拉，她刚刚给我发信息，讲了她过去两到三天一直在进行的独自露营旅行。字面意义上，她离家其实只有一两个小时的车程，
from her home but she's just having the most amazing time and she's doing something that she may not normally do and it's just completely expanded her perspective on her life like in the span of two days just getting out of an old environment and into a new one these are small but mighty choices some more examples you know share your passion your art your hobbies your lifestyle online to a private audience ask new people to go for coffee be spontaneous do something different this weekend that's not your usual sunday reset start putting $20 a week a side purely for a dream fund, just take, you know, those first steps without worrying about them being perfect. And that might not sound like a risky thing to do for some people, but I think anything
但她正过着最美妙的时光，她正在做一些她平时可能不会做的事情，这完全拓宽了她对生活的看法——仅仅在两天的时间里，走出旧环境，进入新环境。这些虽小但充满力量的选择，还有更多的例子，你知道，在线向私密受众分享你的激情、你的艺术、你的爱好、你的生活方式，邀请新认识的人去喝咖啡，随性一点，这个周末做点不一样的、不是你平日周日大扫除的事情，每周存下 20 美元纯粹当作梦想基金，只需迈出那些第一步，而不必担心它们是否完美。对某些人来说，这听起来可能不像是冒险的事，但我认为任何
that goes against the habits, the systems, the routines that you have in place to keep you secure and safe that you are using as a crutch, anything that's like that, that is a risk. That is a risk that you are taking to go against what your natural, deeply ingrained. intuition is telling you to do. What I want you to remember is that you are in charge here of creating a reality you love, creating a version of yourself that you love even more. Sometimes that's going to take courage. The path to reinvention, I think, involves risk and it involves a little bit of fear. So my fifth and my final tip for you today is to stop asking yourself, what if and instead replace that with what else or my favorite so what each of us again has an idea
违背你现有的习惯、体制、常规——那些你用来保持安全稳妥、你把它当作拐杖的东西——任何像这样的事情，都是一场冒险。那是你在冒险，去违背你内心深处根深蒂固的直觉叫你去做的事。我希望你记住的是，你才是这里的主宰，负责创造一个你热爱的现实，创造一个你更热爱的自己。有时这需要勇气。我认为，重塑自我的道路涉及风险，也涉及一点恐惧。所以今天给你的第五个也是最后一个建议是：停止问自己“如果……怎么办”，而是用“还能怎样”或者我最喜欢的“那又怎样”来取代它。我们每个人同样都对
of our truest selves the person that we would be if no one else was watching if this magical switch was turned that suddenly met that you were free from others opinions if the only person we were focused on was ourselves we all had this idea of who we would be in that situation they're almost a fantasy they're a character you know that we've created that we one day aspire to be, but we're not really, not really focused on that right now. Now, the things that are really maintaining that gap between who we are now and who we would really love to be is normally our fear of judgment, our fear of upsetting others and their expectations, our fear of embarrassment of being perceived, that's a huge one, and our fear of change.
最真实的自我有一个概念：如果周围没有人在看，如果这个神奇的开关被按下，突然意味着你摆脱了别人的意见，如果我们关注的唯一对象是我们自己，我们会成为什么样的人。在那种情况下，我们对我们会是谁都有这样一个概念。这几乎是一个幻想，一个你知道我们有一天渴望成为的人物，但我们并不是真的很专注于此。现在，真正维系着“我们现在的样子”与“我们真正想成为的样子”之间差距的，通常是我们对评判的恐惧、对扰乱他人及其期望的恐惧、对尴尬和被注视的恐惧（这是一个巨大的恐惧），以及对改变的恐惧。
These fears are all maintained by these what-if disaster scenarios. If I start putting myself out there, if I start being loud about my hobbies, about my desires, if I start wearing what I want, if I start staying no to people, if I let myself be perceived as my truest authentic self, what if no one likes this version of me? What if I'm ostracized? What if I tell someone about my dreams and I fail? What if people don't like this reinvented version of me? I lose all my friends and I end up alone.
这些恐惧全靠各种“如果……灾难情境”来维持。如果我开始展现自己，如果我对自己的爱好、对自己的欲望高调起来，如果我开始穿我想穿的衣服，如果我开始对别人说不，如果我允许自己作为最真实正宗的自我被别人注视——如果没有人喜欢这个版本的我怎么办？如果我被排挤了怎么办？如果我告诉别人我的梦想却失败了怎么办？如果人们不喜欢我这个重塑后的版本怎么办？我失去了所有的朋友，最后落得孤身一人。
You know, what if, what if? Not only are most of these very social fears, meaning that we are being guided, more so by the potential opinions of others, rather than the reality that we are the only one who has to experience and enjoy our lives, but they are also just anxious thoughts. They are not predictions.
你知道，“如果……怎么办，如果……怎么办？”这些不仅大多是非常社交化的恐惧，意味着我们更多地被他人潜在的意见所引导，而不是被“只有我们自己必须去体验和享受生活”这一现实所引导，而且它们也只是焦虑的想法。它们不是预测。
They most likely not come true. If you've listened to our most recent, episode on anxiety, you'll know that the easiest way to distinguish between an anxious thought and a thought that you should pay attention to is if those thoughts begin with a what if. Here's how we counteract that. We counteract it with what else or so what statements. So let's take this statement. What if I tell everyone about my dreams and I fail?
它们极不大可能会成真。如果你听过我们最近关于焦虑的那期节目，你就会知道，区分焦虑的想法和一个你应该给予关注的想法的最简单方法，就是看这些想法是否以“如果……怎么办”开头。下面是我们如何对此进行反制的。我们用“还能怎样”或“那又怎样”的陈述来反制它。所以让我们拿这句话来说：如果我把自己的梦想告诉所有人然后失败了怎么办？
You know, I'll be so embarrassed. I better play it safe. that's one way of thinking and it is a naturally limited way of thinking but consider now ending that statement with so what okay maybe i'll be embarrassed so what is the worst case scenario i'm embarrassed it's uncomfortable so what so people might not like me so what and then again keep going keep going with the so what's until you get to the final conclusion of your fear and you realize that actually there is not much harm that embarrassment can really do. This method is about taking an anxious, fear-based thought and actually interrogating it,
你知道，我会觉得太尴尬了。我还是求稳比较好。那是其中一种思考方式，这是一种天生受限的思考方式。但现在考虑用“那又怎样”来结束这句话。好吧，也许我会感到尴尬，那又怎样？最坏的情况是什么？我感到尴尬，这让人不舒服，那又怎样？所以人们可能不喜欢我，那又怎样？然后再次继续，不断地用“那又怎样”推进，直到你得出恐惧的最终结论，你就会发现，其实尴尬本身真的造成不了多大伤害。这个方法是关于接受一个基于焦虑、基于恐惧的想法，并真正审视它，
because so often we're too scared to even think about our anxious thoughts that we just let them get away with lying to us. But when we say, so what? Our anxiety kind of is like, oh, well, you've never questioned me before, so I don't really know. I don't really know what's going to happen. And that's when I think we see things more clearly. we see things for what they really are, which is not as big in reality as they are in our minds.
因为通常我们太害怕去思考我们的焦虑想法，以至于我们任由它们对我们撒谎却听之任之。但当我们说“那又怎样？”时，我们的焦虑症就会觉得：“哦，好吧，你以前从未质疑过我，所以我真的不知道，我真的不知道会发生什么。”正是在那个时候，我认为我们能看得更清楚。我们看清了事物的本来面目，它们在现实中其实并没有在我们的脑海中那么大。
The other option is to say, well, what else? What if people don't like this new version of me? Okay, that's one unlikely option, but what else? Let's expand that disaster scenario and go in search of some other alternatives. You know, what if I actually attract people who are really aligned with who I truly am? what if I suddenly meet the greatest friends I'll ever have? What if I suddenly attract a love that I deserve? What if I completely level up every aspect of my life and I never look back?
另一个选择是说，“还能怎样？”如果人们不喜欢我这个新版本怎么办？好吧，这是一种不太可能的选择，但还能怎样？让我们扩大那个灾难情境，去寻找一些其他的替代方案。你知道，如果我实际上吸引到了那些与真正的我真正契合的人呢？如果我突然遇到了我这辈子能遇到的最好的朋友呢？如果我突然吸引到我应得的爱呢？如果我彻底将生活方方面面升级，并且永不回头呢？
What if I am the happiest I have ever been? What else? Remember, the first thought that you have is probably not the most accurate. And you can grab onto that thought. You can let it control you. You can let it dominate your choices, but you also have this extreme power and ability to be whoever you want to be if you just zoom out and question your fear, replacing that what if with what else or so what? During this, you know, brief time that we have on earth, you deserve
如果我是我有生以来最快乐的时候呢？还能怎样？记住，你脑海中的第一个想法可能不是最准确的。你可以抓住那个想法。你可以让它控制你。你可以让它主宰你的选择，但你同时也拥有极大的权力和能力去成为你想成为的任何一个人，只要你拉远镜头，质疑你的恐惧，用“还能怎样”或“那又怎样”来取代那个“如果……怎么办”。在我们在这世上短暂的时光里，你至少应得的
at the bare minimum to actually be yourself. Sometimes we do find ourselves in a loop of not knowing who we are, not liking who we are either, not liking our lives because of boredom, stagnation, you know, isolation. The longer you spend as this version of you, you will become quite used to the discomfort. And you will no longer feel like you have to outgrow that shell. You will just keep squeezing yourself back in, hiding away. And it becomes a lot easier to tolerate. I don't want that for you. To be honest, I don't want that for anyone.
是真正做你自己。有时我们确实会陷入这样一个循环：不知道自己是谁，也不喜欢自己是谁，因为无聊、停滞、孤立而不喜欢我们的生活。你以这个版本的自己度过的时间越长，你就会对这种不适感习以为常。你将不再觉得自己必须超越那个外壳。你会不断把自己塞回原样，躲藏起来。而且它变得更容易忍受了。我不想看到你那样。老实说，我不想任何人那样。
I don't want anyone to be 80 and think, what if I'd just done it a little bit bigger? What if I just had one six-month period of reinvention? Because you have no idea what that could do for your life. You have no idea, you know, how much growth and new experiences you could have in six months. How many weeks is that? Oh my God, I've got to do quick maths, like 24 weeks. I could be completely wrong. Please correct me.
我不想让任何人到了 80 岁时还在想：“要是我当时把事情做得更大一点会怎样？要是我当时经历过长达六个月的重塑期会怎样？”因为你根本不知道那会对你的生活产生什么影响。你根本不知道，你知道的，在六个月内你可以拥有多少成长和新体验。那是几个星期？噢天哪，我得快速算一下，大约 24 周。我可能完全猜错了。请纠正我。
24 weeks, right? Yeah, you could just be a completely new person. That's 24 weeks of time for you to reinvent, transform, invest in yourself. This is an investment. I really want you to take your dream seriously, take responsibility for your happiness, take responsibility for evolving into the most authentic version of yourself, even if that requires a bit of a painful metamorphosis. So I really hope that you got something from this episode. I hope that you got something from this episode. I hope that you can take on board this advice. You know, you can cherry pick it as you wish. If some things you already do, some things you don't, whatever you need, take what you need.
24周，对吧？是的，你完全可以变成一个全新的人。那是长达 24 周的时间，供你重塑、蜕变、投资自己。这是一项投资。我真的希望你认真对待你的梦想，为你的幸福负责，为演变成最真实的自己负责，即使这需要一点痛苦的蜕变。所以我真的希望你从这期节目中有所收获。我希望你从这期节目中有所收获。我希望你能接受这个建议。你知道的，你可以随心所欲地精选采纳。如果有些事情你已经在做了，有些事情你还没做，无论你需要什么，拿走你需要的。
That's what we always say at the end of these episodes. And feel free to send it to someone else who you think might benefit, who you think might enjoy what we've been talking about. As always, five-star reviews are also appreciated, as is a follow either on Spotify or Apple podcasts or on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. if you enjoyed this episode or you have a future episode that you would like to suggest anything to do with psychology, self-help, wellness in our 20s, mental health in our 20s, I would love to hear from you. A final tidbit, we do have an event, a friendship event in Melbourne coming up on the 10th of
这就是我们总在这些节目结束时所说的。欢迎把它分享给你认为可能会从中受益、可能会喜欢我们所谈论内容的人。一如既往，非常感谢五星好评，同样感谢在 Spotify、Apple Podcasts 或 Instagram 上的 @That Psychology Podcast 关注我们。如果你喜欢这期节目，或者你有未来想建议的关于心理学、自助、20多岁时的健康、20多岁时的心理健康的任何主题，我非常期待听到你的声音。最后透露一个小消息，我们在墨尔本有一个活动，一个将于 10 月 10 日举行的友谊活动。
October. I thought I would sneak that in here. So if you are a Melbourne-based listener and you want to make some like-minded friends, you want to meet me. I think we have a few tickets left on a... Event Bright. You can go to our Instagram and there will be a link in our bio. I'm really excited to meet you guys. So let me know if I'm going to see you there. If you'll be there, we'll be doing heaps of other events in Sydney, Brisbane, in Perth, I believe, and then also in the UK and
我本想悄悄把它塞进这里。所以，如果你是一个墨尔本本地的听众，想结交一些志同道合的朋友，想见见我。我想我们在 Eventbrite 上还剩几张票。你可以去我们的 Instagram，在简介里会有一个链接。我真的很兴奋能见到你们大家。所以让我知道我是不是能在那里见到你。如果你会去的话，我们在悉尼、布里斯班、珀斯（我想是的），然后还有英国以及
later next year in the US. So cannot wait to meet you all. Until next time, stay safe, stay kind. Please be gentle with yourselves. You deserve a gentle life and gentle thoughts. And we will talk very, very soon. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with.
明年晚些时候在美国，都会举办大量的其他活动。所以迫不及待想见到你们大家。直到下次，保持安全，保持善良。请对你们自己温柔一点。你值得拥有温柔的生活和温柔的想法。我们很快、很快就会再聊。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·加恩斯带来的《狠狠吸取教训》（Learn the Hard Way）。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在任何地方其实都不安全，但你是在跟一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士谈论它们。有多少男人背负着一副盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《狠狠吸取教训》（Learn the Hard Way）。百分之二。这就是当旁边也有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《百分之二》（2%）中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健康和构建复原力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target.
在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《百分之二》（2%）。当一群女性发现她们约会过的竟是同一个多产的骗子时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。
He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，相信你的好姐妹们。听好姐妹的话。相信我，宝贝，在 iHeart radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回望过去》（Look Back at It）播客中。从 1979 年开始，那对我来说是一个重大时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的人以及我们最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊 80 年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。
black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
黑人。在 iHeart radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回望过去》（Look Back at It）。这是一档 iHeart 播客。人类出品，品质保证。本集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。